so you've really written a new
programming language here yes it is a a
super set of python but you can make a
bunch of different interesting decisions
here totally yeah and you chose actually
to stick with python as a
uh in terms of some of the syntax well
so so let me explain why right so
I mean you can explain this in many
rational ways I think that the
indentation is beautiful but that's not
a rational explanation right so but I
can defend it rationally right so first
of all python one
has millions of programmers yeah it is
huge it's everywhere it owns machine
learning right so actually it is the
thing right second of all if you look at
it C code C plus plus code Java whatever
Swift curly brace languages also run
through formatting tools and get
indented and so if they're not indented
correctly first of all we'll twist your
brain around it can lead to bugs there's
notorious bugs that have happened across
time where The annotation was wrong or
misleading and it wasn't formatted right
and so it turned into an issue right and
so what ends up happening in modern
large-scale code bases is people run
automatic formatters
so now what you end up with is
indentation and curly braces
well if you're going to have
you know the notion of grouping why not
have one thing right and get rid of all
the Clutter and have a more beautiful
thing right also you look at many of
these languages it's like okay well we
can have curly braces or you can omit
them if there's one statement or you
just like enter this entire world of
complicated design space that
objectively you don't need if you have
python style indentation so yeah I would
love to actually see statistics and
errors made because of indentation like
how many errors are made in python
versus in C plus plus that have to do
with basic formatting all that kind of
stuff I would love to see I think it's
it's probably pretty minor because once
you get uh like you use vs code I do too
so if you get vs code setup it does the
indentation for you generally right and
so you don't you know it's actually
really nice to not have to fight it and
then what you can see is the editors
telling you how your code will work by
indenting it which I think is pretty
cool I honestly don't think
I've ever I don't remember having an
error in Python because I indented stuff
wrong yeah so I mean I think that
there's again this is a religious thing
and so I can joke about it and I love I
love to kind of
you know I realized that this is such a
polarizing thing and everyone wants to
argue about and so I like poking at the
bear a little bit right but but frankly
right come back to the first point
python one like it's huge it's an AI um
it's the right thing for us like we see
mojos being an incredible part of the
Python ecosystem we're not looking to
break python or change it or quote
unquote fix it we love python for what
it is our view is that python is just
not done yet
and so if you look at you know you
mentioned python being slow well there's
a couple of different things go into
that which we can talk about if you want
but one of them is it just doesn't have
those features that you would use to do
c like programming and so if you say
okay well I'm forced out of python into
C for certain use cases
well then what we're doing is we're
saying okay well why why is that can we
just add those features that are missing
from python back up to Mojo and then you
can have everything that's great about
python all the things you're talking
about that you love plus not be forced
out of it when you do something a little
bit more computationally intense or
weird or Hardware or whatever it is that
you're doing